I want to apologize because I did end
our relationship abruptly and I know you
didn't come on the show for many years I
didn't know if you were upset with me
I want you to know that I have not dated
a black man since
you've had quite a few high-profile
relationships and I did some digging no
thank you for that I've forgot most of
them so please remind me
I did some digging and I did see a post
that you wrote years ago where you said
50 Cent was your favorite X
okay is he still your favorite ex and
why the hell is he your favorite Act
yeah
he's my favorite acts yeah
well I don't have a favorite X
I mean I I love 50 Cent you know he was
fun he was just a sweetheart and he was
fun to be around my friends loved
hanging out with him I loved hanging out
with him it was a pretty short-lived
romance it was only two months but yeah
I mean if I saw him I definitely have a
drink with him I know that you opened up
recently about your relationship with
Joe um on the Brooke Shields podcast
there was just some behaviors that we
couldn't agree on and it felt to me like
I would have to abandon myself which
maybe I would have been okay to do if I
were 20 or 25 but I wasn't willing to do
that are you guys on good terms yes it
was very sweet to be in a relationship
where so many people wanted you to be
you were running for you like I had
never had a relationship where everyone
was like oh my God this is such a sweet
couple like yeah that gave me
inspiration and it made me believe in
love for everybody and I really believe
that I think that everybody's supposed
to find their person and that
everybody's got a person coming it's
just a matter if you have your blinders
on or not you know the more open you are
the more that comes your way yeah and
the more close off you are the more you
miss